[Musique]
alors les habitués du des cartes
postales vont reconnaître facilement des
images qu'ils proviennent du canada et
ces images sont diffusées par radio
canada international
en direct c'est un thème canada
l'émission du vendredi on accueille les
collègues de différentes sections très
souvent de différentes sections quand on
est chanceux on amène du monde à la
messe comme disent les québécois nota
pour parler d'un sujet en particulier
aujourd'hui on présente nos amis les
26-27 avec nous alléchante hal jordan
est avec nous et puis samir ben ben
jaafer est là aussi
bonjour samir alors évidemment on la
savait que vous savez quoi
au début de chaque émission un principe
vous ne connaissez pas le sujet de
l'émission il semble qu'ils aient eu des
fuites et que comme bien d'autres chats
qui ont parlé tout le monde sait tout
mais apparemment je suis la seule
personne pour la casse à la paf fuite
est le seul qui connaît vraiment le jeu
des missions c'est la vente puisque
c'est lui même qui est à la source de
l'invitation de notre invité de marque
de cette semaine d'accord alors c'est
moi j'ai organisé ça avec lui maintenant
à vous de me dire précisant le sujet
puisqu'il est là vous vous doutez quand
même du contexte général louis sur lui
tout à fait là je les dis tantôt un sens
en présence et évocatrice de quelque
chose je n'ose imaginer que le sujet
c'est mais il faut qu'on ait les images
c'est un vrai pour l'éthique
internationale puisque international
proche et moyen-orient
peut-être ventes d'armes parmi ces
outils
voici les cinq images pour aller à
cibler davantage le sujet aujourd'hui
vous êtes dans le bon secteur le secteur
des affaires étrangères mais de quoi
parle-t-on
c'est ce que la nahdha beau drame un peu
froid dans la rue bellefeuille attendait
frontière non on vous aide pas beaucoup
la jusqu'à maintenant les migrations a
oui c'est la photo la fameuse photo mais
encore quel est le sujet de l'émission
aujourd'hui précisément mais la
coopération internationale
ouais ça fait partie de
multiculturalisme champagne et ses
ministres il était en chine récemment
ça c'est le nouveau ministre st pierre
et c'est par rapport au traitement
réservé par la chine vous l'avez et
nouvelles critiques dans quatre ans on a
un nouveau ministre des affaires
étrangères on n'est pas avec christian
friedel c'est une autre c'est une autre
époque mais voilà on vient de tourner la
page ne vous allez voir à travers cette
émission on va vous montrer les moments
importants depuis dix ans où on a changé
de ministre comme sent responsable des
affaires étrangères c'est qu'il ya eu
des fois des changements de politiques
qui ont été qui ont été avec ce
changement de gouvernance on avait
stéphane dion on se rappelle des choses
très très bien alors aujourd'hui on va
essayer avec quelqu'un qui a écrit un
nouveau livre de voir où ça s'en va tout
ça depuis que l'actuel gouvernement est
en place depuis quatre ans un deuxième
mandat qui devient de maintenance
remporté de justesse ya des critiques
on n'est pas tous fiers de notre
politique internationale et on va avec
le fameux canada is back
louis en aller retour sur la scène
internationale grandes déclarations
d'alain dont l'un sur justin trudeau que
la nsa 2015 après l'élection
je reprenais de mission pendant on
s'aperçoit qu'on a des étudiants en
classe ils sont à suivre qui suivent ce
qui se passe c'est très bien alors je de
la grosse boule premier jeu on perd
combien de points en principe 20 points
si on répond pas correctement à ses
premiers patients évidemment ya trois
questions par émission sans vous la
perdre et voici notre sierro log cette
semaine responsable il ya deux boutons
vous fait tourner les deux bouts de oui
oui on affiche de la question c'est
difficile de vous poser des questions
parce tous des grands spécialistes de la
question de international mais je pense
que voici une colle pour vous en quelle
année selon vous le canada s'est il
officiellement doté d'un ministère des
affaires extérieures
est ce que c'était a en 1869 donc deux
années après la création du canada
est-ce que c'était aussi tard qu'en 1909
non est-ce que c'était c'est en 1939 au
moment où la deuxième guerre mondiale
commençait à se faire accroître ou
est-ce que c'était des parce qu'on a
attendu aussi longtemps qu'en 1959 pour
rayer la police agirait avec la réponse
1 parce que lorsqu'on crée enfin
lorsqu'un pays existe normalement et à
la mise en place de différentes
oui mais je suis en attend pas 2 en
troisième et contient juste un voisin du
sud
t'as pas besoin de créer par rapport à
l'ensemble de la communauté
aucun problème en 1869 demandé c'était
un peu plus difficile de se dépasser à
manger répondre de 1950 1955 puis je
sais pas pourquoi car cette balle de jeu
les casques bleus des choses en tête
c'est vrai c'est l'année des années
casques bleus l'invention du canada
souhaite moi j'irai avec ses 1939 ça me
semble plus après la déclaration de
westminster j'imaginais bien oui moi je
reste sur mon départ
alors on ad on assez épais mais moins
moi je reste avec moi vous restez avec à
voici la bonne réponse vous avez tous
perdu c'est que nous avons tenté tous
éduqués des communes cdc affaires
étrangères
c'est pas à l'examen mais par un des
années comme ça dans notre politique des
affaires étrangères était menée par qui
en notre nom
la bonne voie là alors ça c'est puis les
premières années on n'avait qu' on a eu
que trois ambassades une première c'est
en entendu puis nuit trois ans on
trouvait que c'était beaucoup sa fin je
pense que c'était avec l'angleterre
évidemment les états unis puis l'autre
pays où le france je ne sais pas je n'ai
pas la réponse mais on va jazzer d'être
invités jocelyn coulon politicologue
journalistes politiciens québécois bien
connu aussi chercheur au centre d'études
de recherche international diversité de
montréal de peut-être nous donner
réponse il là comme ça au bout des
doigts c'est un expert lui alors
monsieur couleurs bonjour bonjour
troisième pays avec lesquels on a eu une
ambassade ce serait quoi
je pense que c'est la france ça fait
plaisir aux québécois je suis sûr alors
écoutez c'est une semaine qui a été très
compliqué pour le canada très chargé à
l'otan notamment il ya quelques unes ont
eu quelques échos de sept de ces
rencontres là apparemment un peu partout
dans le monde a fait le tour du monde
verra t on peut en rire d'autres ont
pris ça très au sérieux peut-être même
un peu trop au sérieux mais je lisais
[Musique]
mais la sib ici a publié un article je
pense si ce matin il ya une couple
d'heures à peine en disant qu'il
pourrait y avoir des conséquences
économiques à cette affaire là puisque
trompe semblait suggérer après je
pensais hier mercredi que les pays qui
sont délinquants au niveau du
financement de l'otan pourraient être
appelés à payer au niveau commercial
je sais pas si c'est si ce renvoi on
s'en va vers ça est-ce que c'était
risqué
est-ce qu'on est dans une situation
périlleuse je vous pose comme question
puisque connaissant donald trump
on s'inquiète tous un peu normal oui
écoutez je pense que donald rome en ce
moment est plutôt demandeurs c'est à
dire qu'ils tentent désespérément de
faire adopter le traité de libre-échange
avec le canada et le mexique
et ceux qui bloquent ce sont pas les
républicains ce sont les démocrates de m
donc ce serait très difficile pour trame
de recommencer une guéguerre avec le
canada je pense que c'est un incident
qu'il va pas assez évidemment le
président la mémoire longue
il va certainement retourner à ce qu'il
fait le mieux c'est à dire c'est rude
insulteur tous les chefs d'état sont
passés par là mais à la fin ce qui
compte c'est les relations entre les
états et non pas les relations entre les
individus très bien longtemps maintenant
à votre livre vous avez utilisé
l'expression pas vous personnellement
mais trudeau avait dit si on l'a dit en
début d'émission canada et ce bac et
vous vous y allez de votre propre cru en
disant canada et aux notes barak et on
va montrer les images de ce livre où il
monsieur coulombe et inspiré d'en ligne
j'ai pas est ce que c'est vous qui avez
eu l'idée de la photo pour en prendre
ombrage et moi j'ai eu l'idée de la
couverture en français le livre en
français c'est un selphy avec justin
trudeau wind est une caricature de serge
chapleau
mais en anglais l'éditeur a estimé que
c'était plus
par là la photo de justin en aide
c'est la génération
c'est la position du lotus il n'y a que
les mains qu'il qui le mène au dessus
cela une chose que les gens n'y vont pas
de là c'est plus compliqué à faire
je ne sais que j'ai fait du yoga alors
mais c'est très sérieusement oublions
les crottins parlons de ce que de ce
qu'on a fait depuis cinq ans avec
christian friedel
ça semblait du solide pour plusieurs
puisqu'on a négocié un accord
pratiquement négocier un accord de libre
échange avec les états unis mais vous
dans votre livre vous dites
trudeau ne sait pas vraiment où il s'en
va avec sa politique étrangère
alors moi ce que je dis c'est le slogan
qui a été adoptée en 2015 canada et ce
bac faut savoir pourquoi il a été adopté
moi je n'étais pas très favorable mais
je vous dirai pourquoi
mais lorsqu on s'est réunis parce que
j'étais dans l'équipe de conseillers de
justin trudeau en 2014 2015
on s'est réunis pour créer rédiger une
plate forme de politique étrangère qui
allait se distinguer des conservateurs
parce que la réflexion menée par les
libéraux mais par d'autres c'était que
les conservateurs avaient isolé le
canada sur la scène internationale
et ça ça s'est cristallisée avec la
défaite du canada pour obtenir un siège
au conseil de sécurité en octobre 2010
c'était la première fois depuis soixante
ans que le canada ils étaient battus
pour obtenir un siège au conseil de
sécurité
donc l'équipe de réflexion à rédiger un
programme de politique étrangère qui se
distinguait des des conservateurs d'où
le slogan canada is back
en fait le canada n'était jamais partie
de la scène internationale mais il
n'était pas là où les libéraux voulaient
qu'il soit et je crois que le programme
donnait deux grandes lignes sur le
maintien de la paix
l'aide au développement le dialogue avec
la russie une position équilibrée dans
le conflit israélo palestinien
toute chose qui avait été abandonné par
les conservateurs alice alors monsieur
joue ce même couleur vous estimez que le
canada n'est pas de retour sur la scène
internationale mais on se regarde au
niveau
pardon alizée non ce que ce que je dis
c'est que le canada était sur la scène
internationale à inor à avoue alors il
au canada n'en est jamais sortie n'en
est jamais sortie
les libéraux ont voulu donner une autre
orientation en mettant le canada par
exemple dans les opérations de paix ce
qui n'était pas le cas avec les
conservateurs ils sont allés au mali
mais vous êtes vous connaissez les
circonstances un an au mali malgré que
l'onu avait demandé trois ans mais ce
que nous notons par rapport à cette
politique internationale du canada c'est
que le pays se prononcer clairement sur
différents enjeux
quand on regarde les droits de l'homme
par exemple on a vu dernièrement il ya
eu quelques bisbilles avec l'arabie
saoudite en ce qui a trait aux droits de
l'homme
il ya également des investissements qui
sont annoncés par le finir par le
fédéral pour soutenir l'éducation des
jeunes et la question du genre gender
equity à travers le monde
qu'est ce que vous dites par rapport à
ça est ce que c'est pas une façon pour
le canada de se positionner clairement
sur des enjeux digne d'intérêt
alors moi je pense que ici il ya un
discours il ya une rhétorique et il y à
la réalité c'est bien beau d'envoyer un
tweet pour dénoncer l'arrestation de
trois saoudienne militante des droits
humains
mais si vous n'envoyez pas de tweet pour
dénoncer les bombardements saoudien au
yémen qui tuent des milliers de femmes
et de filles
c'est un drôle de message que vous
envoyer aux femmes et aux filles du
canada et du reste de la planète
ça veut donc dire que vous avez une
politique étrangère qui semble être plus
intéressés aux f
annonce au fait que madame frieden se
rendent à l' aéroport de toronto pour
accueillir une réfugiée saoudienne ça se
fait une belle image surtout en
politique intérieure à un an d'une
élection fédérale
mais ça ne donne rien aux saoudiens
parce que je vous ferai remarquer que
les trois saoudiennes sont toujours en
prison et que monsieur badaoui a
commencé je crois sa neuvième sa
huitième ou neuvième année en prison
donc une grande rhétorique mais peu de
résultats
monsieur coulon moi je vous avais parlé
du conflit au moyen-orient
récemment le canada a approuvé une à
l'onu une résolution qui qui soulève qui
donne droit à parler à
l'autodétermination des palestiniens à
quoi les libéraux ont attendu toutes ces
années pour adopter ce genre de
résolution puisque c'est la même
politique qu'ils adoptent puisqu'ils
sont à leur deuxième mandat alors
n'oublions pas quelque chose lorsque
cette résolution a été adoptée il ya
deux semaines évidemment plusieurs pays
honte à claudie certains groupes ici au
canada ont applaudi mais on a oublié de
mentionner trois jours auparavant
le canada avait voté contre 8 résolution
sur les droits des palestiniens et sur
d'autres questions afférentes au proche
orient
donc finalement les positions adoptées
par les conservateurs pendant dix ans
qui consistait à voter systématiquement
contre toutes les résolutions sur les
palestiniens si poursuivi avec les
libéraux à la notable exception de la
résolution vous avez souligné tout à
l'heure donc le bilan doit toujours être
analysé à travers l'ensemble des
résolutions et pas seulement la
modification d'un vote sur une
résolution le jeu j'aimerais savoir
est-ce que vous pensez que
le nouveau ministre des affaires
étrangères qu'on a ça va changer des
choses est ce qu'on va voir un peu le
retour des politiques de monsieur dion
avec en essayant d'avoir meilleures
relations avec la russie ou des des gros
enjeux comme ça voilà le bilan que je
trace des quatre ans deux du
gouvernement du premier gouvernement
trudeau en politique étrangère nous
oblige à souligner que nous avons des
relations exécrables avec la russie la
chine l'inde et l'arabie saoudite
ce sont quatre pays qui ont un poids
dans le système international comme vous
pouvez vous l'imaginer
et ce sont quatre pays qui ont une
grande capacité de nuisance à
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
et nous pourrions en faire les frais en
juin 2020 lorsque le vote se tiendra
afin de départager le canada l'irlande
la norvège pour obtenir un des deux
sièges au conseil de sécurité
donc nous avons mal joué nos cartes
et bien entendu tout ne repose pas sur
le canada toutes les responsabilités ne
repose pas sur le canada dans les
relations difficiles que nous avons avec
ces quatre pays
mais je vous ferai remarquer que nous
sommes le 6 dental qu'ils soient dans
cette configuration c'est assez
exceptionnel
moi je n'ai jamais vu ça oui j'aimerais
vous paraît encore davantage de cet
homme qu'on voit présentement à l'écart
parce que c'est un inconnu pour nous ici
à la station vous imaginez pour
l'ensemble des canadiens qui seraient à
l'ecoute marc andré deschamps si vous
habitez au québec dans son comté vous
savez qui il est
autrement vous demander qu'il est moi
j'ai cherché des entrevues
oui s'est exprimé on trouvait une couple
à radio canada mais il n'a pas accordé
d'entrevue depuis qu'il a été nommé
ministre des affaires extérieures à ma
connaissance ne sont pas remises en
question par oui
ouais et alors qui est scellé cobaty de
faire alors pour rebondir et sur votre
question et sur la question de l'even
c'est sûr que monsieur champagne n'est
pas un idéologue comme madame christiane
frileux et on a bien vu pendant les
trois années où madame frilet n'était là
qu'elle avait des idées bien arrêtées
alors qu'en diplomatie il faut savoir
aussi composer dialoguer être flexible
d'autant plus que le canada est une
nation commerçante
une très grande partie de sa richesse se
fait avec le commerce bien entendu avec
les états unis
c'est pour ça qu'on sourit à chaque fois
que donald trump nous insultent parce
qu'on n'a pas vraiment parce qu'on n'a
pas vraiment le choix
donc je crois que le taux va changer
avec monsieur champagne qui est un
pragmatique et quelqu'un qui aime avoir
des résultats
et à chaque fois qu'on va lui proposer à
chaque fois qu'on on va le mettre devant
un problème
eh bien il va demander des solutions et
des solutions concrètes et non pas de
grands discours théorique sur les
relations internationales
donc au moins cet aspect là devrait
améliorer l'atmosphère de nos relations
avec avec ces quatre pays
est ce que vous pensez qu'il va voire
l'indépendance pour agir dans ce dossier
là alors c'est une très bonne question
parce que à l'époque où stéphane dion
l'été ministre des affaires étrangères
et qu'il a essayé par exemple d'ouvrir
le dialogue avec la russie
madame frieling a mis les bâtons dans
les roues
à chaque fois et donc madame frieden
demeure la vice première ministre
des fois on peut se demander si elle
n'est pas premier ministre bis dans ce
pays
alors elle sera certainement autour de
la table du conseil de mini des
ministres très attentive à ce que
monsieur champagne va dire sur les
relations avec les pays avec qui les
choses ne vont pas très bien
chantal vos réponses ont été très très
alarmiste d'entrée de jeu par rapport à
la politique étrangère du canada à vous
entendre on a l'impression que c'est une
politique qui a besoin d'être
dépoussiéré
dites moi c'est quoi le remède c'est
quoi la solution pour remettre la
politique étrangère du canada sion de
bons rails alors je pense que la
première chose que ce champagne a déjà
commencé à faire d'ailleurs c'est le
dialogue s'est retrouvé le sens du
dialogue qui a toujours caractérisé la
politique étrangère depuis au point 1945
je vous ferai remarquer seul exemple en
lester b pearson qui était ministre des
affaires étrangères a été le premier
ministre des affaires étrangères
occidental à se rendre à moscou pour
rencontrer les successeurs de staline
pas parce qu'il les aimait
mais ils voulaient savoir plus qu'est ce
qu'ils avaient dans le ventre et essayer
d'établir un espèce de dialogue à un
moment où il y avait un changement de
régime en union soviétique et peut-être
même le début d'un dégel
c'est ça le canada alors malheureusement
ça n'a pas été le cas
je ne parle pas seulement un problème
les dix ans de gouvernement
conservateurs n'ont pas été aussi ouvert
alors je pense que la période 2006
19 a été difficile pour notre diplomatie
nous avons perdu un siège au conseil de
sécurité
nous avons des relations exécrables avec
ses quatre grands pays donc il est temps
de reprendre le dialogue
ça me semble être la première condition
la deuxième c'est de se servir des
fonctionnaires des diplomates qui
travaille au ministère des affaires
étrangères et qui ont des idées
les conservateurs les avaient ignoré
pendant dix ans et d'une certaine façon
les quatre dernières années on a établi
bien entendu le dialogue avec les
fonctionnaires mais pas assez ce sont
eux qui pensent la politique étrangère
et donc ce serait intéressant de les
écouter plus souvent ce que l'on
j'aimerais parler du cas particulier de
la chine nous avait parlé des quatre
points avec lesquels on a des
difficultés mais la chine ça semblerait
être à mes yeux en tout cas de non
expert problème parce qu'avant épineux
mais en regard de des relations plutôt
extraordinaire qu'on a cultivé avec la
chine depuis 1973 lorsque le père de
justin trudeau pierre elliott trudeau
s'était rendu en chine avait reconnu 79
savez fait tout un tout un bruit
internationalement la chine avait été
très reconnaissante envers le canada
pour ses gestes diplomatiques très
important il semble qu'on ait perdu un
capital énorme mais est-ce que céder les
apparences c'est un jeu d'apparence ou
c'est en réalité profondément on a un
problème sérieux
ben c'est sûr que les relations avec la
chine ne seront plus ce qu'elles étaient
avant l'arrestation dans la main et
l'arrestation bien sûr des des deux
canadiens
nous allons devoir réfléchir un peu plus
sur le sens à donner à notre relation
avec la chine
en même temps nous savons très bien que
la meilleure façon de desserrer l'étau
américain qui se resserre sur le canada
il faut pas oublier que
oui on va avoir un nouvel accord de
libre échange qui va nous intégrer
encore plus dans l'économie américaine
mais nous avons des relations militaires
qu'on oublie souvent de signal et qui
nous intègrent dans les stratégies
militaires américaines alors une façon
pour le canada de gagner 10 ont un peu
plus d'indépendance vis-à-vis des
etats-unis c'est de multiplier les
relations sur la scène internationale et
surtout de diversifier notre économie et
la diversification
elle commence et elle se poursuit
surtout avec l'asie j'ai l'impression
que nous avons fait le plein avec avec
l'europe n'aurait l'afrique
aussi il faudrait penser sérieusement à
l'afrique parce que vous savez que dans
trente ans populations africaines votre
double y repasser de 1.2 milliard à 2.5
milliards
c'est pas pour harry que le brésil la
turquie l'inde l'allemagne le japon sont
sur le continent africain et même
organise des sommets de chefs d'état
africains avec leurs vis-à-vis japonais
et indiens ou brésiliens
alors pour revenir à la chaîne je pense
que nous n'avons pas le choix de
poursuivre cette relation
je trouve même que le gouvernement se
comporte très bien c'est à dire qu'il a
il a adopté une position de low profile
dans cette affaire ne pas faire de
vagues de négocier calmement
discrètement et ça donnera certainement
des résultats oui - l'autre pouvoir et
on a parlé des relations
un commercial c'est l'inde c'est un
pouvoir qu'on oublie souvent et on a eu
cette plusieurs experts qui ont dit que
la visite désastreux de monsieur être
doha langue qu'est ce qui se passe avec
les relations avec l'inde
la plupart des experts estiment que
l'inde va devenir la deuxième troisième
puissance économique du monde dans une
vingtaine d'années 25 ans ça veut donc
dire que le canada doit se positionner
sur ce marché est à l'évidence là le
voyage de l'année dernière à dix on july
ses relations pour pour quelques années
c'est très dommage il faut là encore ré
apprendre l'art du dialogue et surtout
surtout être sensible aux situations
locales
l'inde est un pays démocratique qui
depuis 1948 essaie de tenir ensemble 1.2
milliard d'habitants le multiple de
multiples races langues cultures
cohabitent en inde
et lorsque le premier ministre canadien
arrive fait un petit tour de piste avec
ses vêtements
mais surtout surtout amène avec lui
quatre ministre sic il envoie un
vraiment un drôle de message au
gouvernement indien et aux indiens et je
pense que le bureau du premier ministre
a manqué de finesse ici on entend pour
une dernière question
samir ben écoutez moi je voudrais savoir
quel serait l'avenir de la des relations
internationales du canada avec un peu
l'afrique du nord et le moyen
comment vous les voyez je parlais volume
on a des relations importantes avec
l'afrique du nord en fait lorsqu'on
regarde nos échanges avec le continent
africain
on se rend compte que essentiellement
ces relations se font avec les trois
grands pays du maghreb le maroc
l'algérie la tunisie
évidemment nous avons aussi des
relations avec le nigeria l'afrique du
sud et d'autres pays
mais le gros des relations avec
l'afrique se fait avec ces trois pays
je pense que ces relations vont se
poursuivre
il y a des diasporas de ces trois pays
essentiellement au québec à montréal et
sont très importants on a des liaisons
aériennes presque quotidiennes et je
pense que ces relations vont se
poursuivre yvon ça vont même
s'approfondir
est ce que est ce que monsieur trudeau
est encore susceptible de vous appeler
pour des conseils
après ce soir vous étiez et tout ce
qu'il dit aussi je je pense pas je pense
pas mais vous seriez surpris de voir
combien de deux membres de ce
gouvernement ou même d'ambassadeurs en
poste qui me parlent très bien c'est
bercy nous avons parlé là nous
aujourd'hui force est alors c'est donc
monsieur jocelyn coulon politicologue
journalistes politiciens québécois très
connus grands journalistes notamment ou
de voir si mes souvenirs sont bons
vraiment c'est quelqu'un que moi je
regarde beaucoup d'additions lorsque je
m'informais relativiser système est très
inspirant c'est sûr écouter entre
tergnier avec ses images de son livre ça
c'est la version anglaise son livre
d'accord et le self iwuy son web
voilà alors sans trop dire deux choses
voici quel était le titre du précédent
livre
dan ellis politique de jocelyn coulon et
là une petite erreur je vous donnais un
choix de réponse sioniste est rare mais
général accident pendant la question
mais dans la réponse oui alors si vous
découvrez l'erreur dans la réponse je
vous offre des points de plus et si vous
n'avez pas la bonne réponse
est-ce que c'est compliqué la fiche
qu'elle était le livre du précédent à le
délai de titre du précédent livre
d'analysé politique de jocelyn coulon
est ce que c'était a les affaires
commerciales avant les affaires
étrangères est-ce que c'était b grand
pays avec petit pouvoir
est-ce que c'était c1 selphy avec justin
trudeau où est ce que c'était dès le le
brûle mais avec le des fêtes les plus
meilleurs c'est déjà une erreur à allah
ya même un on peut pas de l'affichage de
la hune superlatif absolu doublé d'un
autre superlatif absolu pendant que ça
donne ça donne une faute il ya aussi un
c'est ça qu'on peut pas le plus meilleur
pays au monde
moi ce serait le ya aucune de ces
réponses ça peut pas l'afficher t il ya
aussi pour moi c'est le ccsf et avec
juste un truc non s'installe fils et
celui là je mélange l'attendent alors
vous avez trouvez l'erreur
félicitations le premier c'était pas le
dernier et le précédent c'est l'actuel
d'accord je leur promets point où vous
avez non seulement des points mais vous
donc je m'entends avec 120 points
maintenant ouest exactement et ce à quoi
répond c'est le plus meilleur pays au
monde selon british je sais pas c'est
quoi la bonne réponse de son précédent
livre je bouge je sais pas je n'ai pas
la réponse mais du coup je me suis amusé
ropert d'équilibré je suis avoir du
plaisir et 150 personnes de perdre deux
points mais ils augmentent en progressif
de son berceau
un besoin de son vin nous en avons en
inversant j'en avais perdu vingt neuf
fois pour venir gagner 30 ça fait
combien 110 110 110 les autres ont 80
c'était pas bon en mathématiques en les
copains j'ai une petite affaire pour
vous pour ceux qui veulent en savoir
davantage sur la politique
internationale
moi le premier parce qu'il faut que je
m'en fous moi aussi et souvent je
consulte les sites web de radio-canada
intentions pour savoir ce que vous avez
écrit précédemment à savoir comment vous
l'avez dit c'est pas évident et parce
que l'histoire ça bouge rapidement en
politique et nationale s'est passé il ya
eu françois champagne français du sang
alors on défile si vous êtes capable de
lire la moitié des titres et qui sont
inscrits dites le moi
la chine n'est pas un adversaire du
canada ce qui se disait récemment le
ministre la défense du canada
l'ambassadeur a été un peu un peu de
temps c'est le canada mais bon et puis
le canada votre contre israël à l'onu
vous en avez parlé un peu plus tôt et je
pense que chris est un prénom ne restera
dans le futur en pense le vin puisque
l'addition commun skymark râle quand on
part là dans le futur de de l'époque de
la politique étrangère canadienne est ce
qu est ce que chris afriland sortira du
lot mais bien sûr c'est que si t'as pas
une ministre
effacée à la même énervé 30 à la sortie
de ses gonds donc il ya marie jobin qui
est écrit est un sujet à son titre
s'était passé j'ai vu ça ce matin j'ai
trouvé ça on se demandait si elle allait
sortir un peu des polaires politique
étrangère ou savez c'est dedans
non mais apparemment les négociations
wingles et lui c'est les années harper
oui alors voyons remonte dans le temps
facilement grâce à ces articles à
christophe yvelines qui avait dit qu'il
a dit ce matin où il hier au sujet de la
vidéo aux etats unis la fin positive
nîmes la vidéo virale que ça ne devrait
pas affecter fondamentalement les
relations des deux pays qu'il ya
beaucoup de points de divergence mais
que fondamentalement les deux arrivent à
se parler
la salle elle n'a fait que réitérer la
position du officiel
mais la vidéo a été utilisé par le camp
adverse de trompes publicité qui relie
ce job et qui est qui et les premières
publicités qui a vraiment marqué un but
dans un second plusieurs analyses en a
qui vont en faire un capital politique
commune comme monsieur collomb a dit
trompé il a une mémoire très
éléphantesque les fantoches donc on
retrouvera peut-être dans un tweet
prochain tweet
écoutez on est légèrement délinquants
d'après top il aurait pu me dire pire
que ça un show suis sûr on y prête la
troisième question
la grosse boule est assez sérieux vous
allez tous perdent des points d'accord
pas d' excuses 50 boules à perdre au et
voici la question la fiche pour tout le
monde le nombre de canadiens interdit de
séjour
interdit de séjour aux états unis ses
marques et interdiction mais interdit de
séjour aux états unis a augmenté depuis
un an de quel pourcentage selon vous
c'est
je vous laisse j'ai pas fais des choix
de 50 % à 200 %
oui bon bah moi je vais avec 150 % j'ai
vu passer c'était très rapide en place
vous inscrire avec des 200 % des 200%
pour notre copain la bonne on réitère
votre réponse
cent cinquante pour cent cinquante pour
ça pour alice
et qui dit mieux moi j'irai pour cent
pour cent soit pour ce que j'ai entendu
parler de ça à doubler ou quelque chose
comme ça mais j'ai pu voir quelques
points par 650 pour ça c'est un petit je
me rappelle c'est un petit chiffre s'est
passé par milliers c'est quelque chose
de petit que ça a doublé ses bébés on va
aller pour b on va aller montrer la
bonne réponse la régie vous indique
maintenant la bonne réponse qui remporte
haut
il ya plus d'interdictions sais pas
pourquoi la politique américaine n'a pas
changé sauf que le président est plus
sévère envers les migrations peut-être
avec
avec avec la loi sur l'eau marie quoi la
marijuana est pas sain parce que ça
aussi c'est est ce que les bords et
portage disait que souvint les officiers
de franquin services frontaliers qui
travaillent peut-être sur la côté
mexicain à ils ont été ceux semble
beaucoup plus sévère maintenant à
l'assassin bondés des petites choses qui
peut avoir des gros conséquence il faut
jour toujours dû dire du bien des
douaniers américains parce que ma
démission sinon c'est pour te ramasser à
qu'il régale
parce qu'il va garde tout oui on sait
maintenant ils peuvent aller sur
facebook qu'on a déclaré on peut
regarder votre téléphone à l'intérieur
oui un des leurs mots de passe
on a pas on peut pas refuser au canada
ça a été ou est ce que ça a été dit que
c'est un coup ça s'est rendu il ya
quelque chose en cours en ce moment ok
on est prêt pour l'image la semaine on
tourne la page complètement l'image la
semaine écoutez vous avez tous une image
certainement en tête c'est peut-être pas
la mienne d'un trident matran et oui
c'est avec la vidéo avec la princesse
anne où on va voir regardez
si vous avez la bonne réponse c'est fou
comme robert biever tôt que mais c'est
mes services des surfaces
malheureusement je regarde la vidéo de
0,8 qui nous donne la réponse
à l'image la semaine a alors montré des
images de siby si c'est la vidéo de
cilicie qu'on vous montre mais ça a été
repris par tous d'un monde voilà en
anglais c'est sympathique ce qu'on
entend la voix des choses en face on se
demande de quoi il parle
ils peuvent plus boire beaucoup et bus
il buvait beaucoup
c'est un camion civil et j'escompte que
le geste était autorisé le canada est
beau c'est un double double visage ouais
général x pict et ses coups de gueule
qui était à côté voir les corps on
dirait qu'il est assis sur des artisans
show la bête comme elle le disait notre
invité trump a besoin du canada en ce
moment pour passer quelque chose toutes
les questions
pour une fois on a peut-être le groupe
du bob variations très très mesuré bien
sûr ce qui surprend toujours
regarde pas il n'a pas besoin de lui
tenir le bras comme la dernière fois
pour qui le bousculent pas mon premier
au début
voilà ça c'est le hasard sur soi les h2k
c'est la dernière fois que il ya eu un
problème politique en juin de l'an
dernier
merci beaucoup ainsi bbc pour ces images
très gentil de leur part de ne prêter ce
matériel qui après tout nous appartient
est-ce que vous il ya vous vouliez
ajouter quelque chose parce qu'il reste
encore six minutes de signaux gratuit
alors qu'est ce mois a ajouté
on attend dé vous baladant fication de
la lune moi je devrais me demander des
questions concernant le discours tron
qu'on a eu un
jamais la politique étrangère était le
dernier point qui était mentionné dans
le discours ce a rejoint les idées de
de monsieur coulant que oui enfin ça
c'était intéressant qui vont encore
essayer d'aller chercher ses sièges dans
le conseil en sécurité mais aussi
renforcer il faut renforcer le
partenariat avec la chine et les
partenaires à l'otan et les autres
d'autres pays occidentaux
alors c'est vraiment c'était vraiment
intéressant de voir sa réaction est
aussi s'il avait écouté l'ambassadeur
chinois rentière cécile commentait un
peu il nous a dit l'ambassadeur chinois
nouvel ambassadeur au canada 3 du mary
cohr ou de ce qui se passerait si ça ne
regarde pas parce que ça se passe en
chine
grimpez grande nation fière d'elle sauf
qu'il oublie que quand il est question
des droits de l'homme
ça ne concerne plus qu'un pays ça
concerne le monde entier
sept points sur 7 1.17 en perse
c'est une question des droits non je
faisais l'avocat le canada est
signataire des différentes conventions
internationales sur les droits de
l'homme et devraient normalement avoir
son mot à dire partout dans le monde où
les droits de l'homme ceux qui doivent
le dire que ce monsieur goulet quelque
part c'est aussi une atteinte à la
liberté d'expression on est libre de se
prononcer sur quelques dossiers que ce
soit d'accord donc un ambassadeur nasa a
limité intéressant parce que quand ça un
ambassadeur dit quelque chose comme ça
c'est comme ils nous provoquent de un
fait si quelqu'un dit aux canadiens vous
ne pouvez pas y aller c'est sûr qu'ils
vont y aller
les endroits tout à fait parce que si ça
se fait discrètement peut-être là on va
en rien quand j'aurai un mais quand
c'est ouvertement comme ça je me demande
si
le parlement où le sénat qui va qui va
adopter cette motion va sentir cette
pression de réagir contre la chaîne
sur ce point je voulais lui demander
discuter de ça c'est la notion
d'ingérence dans les affaires des pays à
partir de quel moment ça commence
ingérence est-ce que des décades
ambassadeur paraissent que sais je sais
pas si c'est flexibles ou s'est fixé ça
fait l'objet d'une fuite dans les
journaux c'est l'agir ça serait quand
amis parce que c'est des sujets quand
même assez délicat c'est aussi dans ce
cas là l'ambassadeur chinois pao
directement de la politique canadien
envers la chine et alors mais si c'était
quelque chose qui était avec la
politique intérieure canadienne la place
et on appelle ça comme ça l'ex trop
gênant je pense qu'il ya un droit
d'ingérence
sur le plan international le droit
international quand pour des raisons
humanitaires d'affaires du groupe est
validée
tout à fait donc il ya un droit
d'ingérence qui permet à des pays
d'intervenir en situation critique
c'est une politique qui était avancée
par notre ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères le dos mais c'est pas
accepter l'argent partout sur tout le
pays comme chine la russie
l'iran les qui ont des problèmes avec
les droits de l'homme ou d'autres
interprétations des droits de l'homme
sont pas eu d'accord c'est normal ce
n'est pas noir ou blanc
et puis ils ont l'alluré d'un veto sur
tout mais surtout la russie et chine
écoutez merci beaucoup pour notre tour
de géopolitique c'est très agréable on a
passé par l'afrique du nord oui on va
passer par tous les toutes les tous les
continents sauf un continent sauf
nécessairement je préfère c'est que
quelque part peut-être dans une
programme ambitieux peut-être à bastien
prochaine mission mentalement oui
française c'est quoi ce serait
intéressant
ouais alors une de ses prochaines
émissions pas la prochaine parce qu'on
veut quand même continuer à jouer à la
découverte du jeu fait deviner le sujet
cette semaine à la semaine prochaine
tous les endroits
[Musique]